- [Voiceover] Two tornadoes
ongoing right now.
- [Voiceover] Oh my God.
(upbeat band music)
- [Voiceover] It takes a certain craziness
for people to go out
and pursue these things.
- [Voiceover] God, oh my God.
- The raw destruction of nature
in such a tight, enclosed area.
It's tragic, it's amazing, it's beautiful
and every one, for me,
holds that sense of awe and wonder.
Here it comes.
My name is Tony Laubach
and I am a storm chaser
and meteorologist.
I basically make a living out in the field
selling imagery to news
outlets, telling the story
in a visual sense, of what's
happening with weather.
From March to June,
I'm basically traveling
all over the country in
search of severe weather,
literally could be
putting tens of thousands
of miles on my car.
Sometimes 5000 miles a week.
Large tornado on the
ground, west of Dodge City.
The storm we've been on is
weakening pretty heavily
right now.
The storm coming out of the South
I think, has got my attention right now.
It's something I'm kinda watching.
(banjo music)
Kansas has always been my holy land.
The flatlands, the fields, the colors.
For a normal person, you
drive from Kansas City
to Colorado and you
gotta spend eight hours
driving through nothing.
To chasers, to people like me,
it's the most beautiful
landscape of anything.
You can see tens if not
hundreds of miles at a time
and watch these storm
from a great distance.
It's something truly amazing.
There it is.
We as chasers never, ever want storms
to impact anybody in a negative way.
And unfortunately, in
some instances, they do,
significantly.
They take lives and peoples
homes and their livelihoods.
(piano music)
The lows are devastating but the highs
are amazing, because of the gratification,
the beauty, everything that you have put
the effort into is there.
When you get rewarded by
nature for your efforts,
and you see this event in
person, there's nothing
that compares to that.